i've been in the conservatorship for 13
years
it's a really long time to be in a
situation you don't want to be in um so
i'm just grateful honestly for each day
britney spears is celebrating her
newfound freedom and teasing a possible
sit down with oprah winfrey i just i get
so excited about it on tuesday the pop
star posted this clip to instagram
opening up to her fans about life since
her conservatorship was terminated last
week being able to have
the keys to my car and being able to be
independent and feel like a woman and
um owning an atm card seeing cash for
the first time being able to buy candles
it's the little things for us women but
it makes
a huge difference
and
i'm grateful for that you know it's nice
it's really nice
and despite everything the 39 year old
lucky singer has been through she said
she's not here to be a victim
i
worked for 20 years and worked my ass
off i'm here to be advocate for people
with real disabilities and real
illnesses
i'm a very strong woman so i can only
imagine um what the system has done to
those people
so hopefully my little story
hopefully my story will make an impact
and
make some changes
in the corrupt system britt also
addressed the free britney movement
crediting it with saving her life
you guys
rock honestly my voice was muted and
threatened for so long and um i wasn't
able to speak up or say anything and um
because of you guys in the awareness of
kind of knowing what was going on
and delivering that news to the public
for so long you gave it awareness um to
all of them and um because of you i
honestly think you guys saved my life in
a way 100
and she wrapped up her post on a sweet
note let's move forward god bless you
all we're gonna have a good year good
christmas and rock pond
now get this in the caption brit dropped
one big five letter word oprah she wrote
in part quote i might as well do a hint
of my thoughts on the gram before i go
and set things square on oprah
um did she just tease an oprah exclusive
oh my gosh
it's so good and well we'll just have to
wait to see what happens with that the
singer went on saying that it still
blows her mind that her family and the
conservatorship were quote able to do
what they did to her adding quote it was
demoralizing and degrading what's next
for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade is up to one
person
brittany
of course on friday a los angeles judge
ruled to terminate the conservatorship
that has controlled britney's career and
finances for nearly 14 years
i will say that brittany has been put
into a position
through our collaboration in the work of
my law firm
to succeed
we have a safety net in place for
brittany both on the personal side
and on the financial side as those of
you who are in court understand
but brittany as of today
is a free woman
and she's an independent woman
and the rest with her support system
will be up to brittany
after the decision britney posted this
message to her instagram thanking her
fans
quote good god i love my fans so much
it's crazy i think i'm gonna cry the
rest of the day best day ever praise the
lord can i get an amen
freed brittany
[Music]
you